like an energy independence is a false
goal we're never going to be energy
independent because oil and energy is
fungible oil moves around but we
certainly can become less dependent on
foreign oil and oil from countries that
don't like us and that I think is our
should be our goal and that's where we
should focus ourselves we're going to
need to do more in conservation we're
going to need to do more in renewable
resources and we're going to need to
look at the base power that we have
today and we need to do more with things
like nuclear energy that's an important
part its twenty percent of our power
today if you care about climate change
if you care about air quality nuclear is
the only form of base power that does
not emit any of the regulated pollutants
while is producing power we're going to
have coal it's going to be part of our
futures or the fifty percent of our
energy today we need to make sure it's
low so for coal and that it's burned as
cleanly as possible and that we
understand what we can do with the co2
that is emitted we're going to have to
have all of these things there's no one
silver bullet